in this lesson we're going to talk about
rationalizing denominators so these
problems oftentimes occur on the act see
if you can do these two examples we'll
go through them together talk about how
to rationalize denominators so the first
one it says which is equivalent to 3
divided by the square root of 2 minus 1.
we've got some multiple choice options
here and example 2 says which is
equivalent to 4 divided by square root
of 3 minus i where i equals square root
of negative 1 and again we've got some
multiple choice options so go ahead and
pause the video see if you can do these
on your own and we'll go through them
together
okay so the first one we don't want this
radical in the denominator that's
considered improper so how do we get rid
of that radical well when it's a
binomial like this what you want to do
is you want to multiply by the conjugate
now what's the conjugate well the
conjugate is going to be the same two
terms that we have here except for we're
going to change that sign in between
these two terms to the opposite so you
can see here i have square root of 2
minus 1 we're going to multiply by
square root of 2 plus 1
but whatever you do to the denominator
you want to do to the numerator because
anything divided by itself is 1 and then
1 times this fraction will
have the same value it'll just be in a
different format
so what we're going to do here is we're
going to think of this as a group okay
like so
and we're going to distribute the 3 to
both of these terms so that gives us 3
square root of 2
plus 3 okay and then here we're going to
foil or do the distributive property
twice depending how you think about it
so square root of 2 times square root of
2
is going to give us 2 because square
root of 2 times square root of 2 is
square root of 4 square root of 4 is 2
and then square root of 2 times 1 gives
us positive square root of 2 and then
the negative 1 when we distribute gives
us negative square root of 2 and
negative 1 times positive 1 gives us
negative 1. okay one thing that you'll
notice here is that the
inside terms the inner and the outer are
going to cancel one another out so
square root of 2 and negative square
root of 2 they cancel
2 minus 1 of course is just 1. and so
we've got 3 square root of 2 plus 3 all
divided by 1. anything divided by 1 is
itself
so it looks like the best answer here is
going to be letter c
3 square root of 2 plus 3.
okay let's go on to example number 2.
it says which is equivalent to 4 divided
by the square root of 3 minus i where i
equals the square root of negative 1.
okay a couple things going on here we've
got a radical in the denominator as well
as an i the imaginary i right we both we
don't want square roots in the
denominator we also don't want i's in
the denominator so what we're going to
do is we're going to multiply by the
conjugate just like we did here except
for this at a time it's called the
complex conjugate because this is a
complex number it's part real part
imaginary but all we really need to know
is
change that sign in between the two
terms to the opposite and so we're going
to do the same thing to the numerator
and the denominator and if we do this
let's see what we get we get 4 times
square root of 3
which is 4 square root of 3 4 times i
which is 4i
and then in the denominator we get
square root of 3 times square root of 3
which is 3 because that's square root of
9 right square minus 3. square root of 3
times i just gives us square root of 3
i okay square root of 3i
negative i times square root of 3 gives
us negative square root of 3i
and then negative i times positive i
gives us negative i squared
okay now we talked about this in a
another lesson but i squared is actually
equal to negative 1
and times this negative would make this
a positive 1 plus 3 is 4.
the square root of 3i and the negative
square root of 3i they cancel one
another out and so we're left with 4
square root of 3 plus 4i all over 4. now
what you can do here is you can split
this up into two groups
like that so split it up into two
fractions and then you can divide you
know these fours so that will just give
you square root of three and then these
fours which will just give you i so the
best answer here is going to be square
root of three plus i and that's going to
be
letter b so this is how you rationalize
radicals and
eliminate the radical and denominator or
the i in the denominator if you just
have a monomial i'll just mention real
quick here like one term like say it's
square root of two you don't have to
multiply by the conjugate you can just
multiply by square root of 2 over square
root of 2 because square root of 2 times
square root of 2 is 2. there you go
you've eliminated the square root of the
denominator and then you have 4 square
root of 2 in the numerator and then the
4 and the 2 those are both integers you
can reduce those and just get 2 square
root of 2. but if it's a binomial like
these you want to multiply by the
conjugate i'll see in the next lesson